>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> A few weeks ago, we made a public
call for researchers, librarians
and technologists to share how
they are applying the Collections
as Data concept to their work.
Each of these speakers will have
five minutes throughout this session
to talk about their projects.
We will hear from Steven Weinberger,
Chelsea Stieber, Kevin Schlottmann,
Ascension Mazuela-Anguita,
Ed Summers, Paul Farber,
Jared Nielsen, and William Ferster.
Steven.
>> I'm Steven Weinberger.
I'm the director of linguistics
at George Mason University.
I'm a phonologist by training,
and I study speech accents.
And we've put together a
little speech accent database
at George Mason University.
So how did this begin?
In 1999, I gave an assignment
to my phonetics class
and they were interested
in teaching ESL.
And so they went out and
recorded non-native speakers
and they used all sorts of
magnetic tape and different kinds
of tape recorders,
and we systematized it
and put it on the web.
And it's been on the web since 1999.
In 2002, it was picked up and is now
hosted by the Roy Rosenzweig Center
for History and New
Media at George Mason.
I want to thank them
for keeping it up.
What's the purpose of this archive?
To demystify and to
scientifically study speech accents,
English accents, by the way.
And the database continues
to expand.
The Corpus has currently --
today it has 2399 samples,
310 native language
backgrounds from ASL to Zulu,
175 countries are represented,
there's 165,462 words at the moment.
It's used by a variety of visitors
like linguists, ESL teachers,
engineers, speech pathologists,
actors, and most of the time,
people doing drinking games.
These are all the languages that are
represented -- language backgrounds.
Everyone is reading the
same English paragraph.
That's what makes the
archive a bit unique.
The architecture includes an
elicitation paragraph audio sample
-- oh, I can look down here --
some demographic information about
each speaker, maps of locations,
phonetic transcriptions, which I'll
show you an example of in a moment,
phonological speech patterns
like what makes a German speaker
different from a Zulu speaker
of English, segment inventories
of each of the native languages,
and it also has the opportunity
for remote researchers to send
in accents from all over the world.
And it has a search facility, 69
words in the elicitation paragraph.
It's the famous "please call Stella"
paragraph -- famous to me, at least.
That's the whole paragraph.
Everyone reads it.
We have a strict recording
protocol, it's CD quality,
and we reduce it to MP3 128 bits.
And let's see if this
will work for you.
You can listen to some
of these things.
Everyone recognizes an accent
as soon as they can hear it.
Tell me if you think
this is a non-native.
>> Please call Estelle.
>> Can we turn it up a little bit?
I'll do it again.
>> Please call Estelle.
>> Please call Stella.
>> Can you hear all that?
>> Anyway, those are
three non-natives.
Can you guess the languages?
No. The first one is Amharic, the
second one is Mandarin Chinese,
and the third one is Russian.
You can listen to them on your own
at another point on the archive.
The speaker demographics
come like this.
We asked them their native language.
Of course there are 310
of them at the moment.
It's linked to an Ethnologue code.
We asked what other languages they
know, residency includes place
of birth, English language
residents,
length of English residency,
the gender of the individual,
the age of the individual,
the English onset age,
and the learning style.
Everyone's asked the
same seven questions.
So this is all searchable
information.
And there's room for some notes.
Here is the paragraph transcribed
with our funny phonetic
alphabet that linguists use.
I don't know if you'll
be able to hear this.
Let's see.
This is a --
>> Please call Stella.
Ask her to bring these things
with her from the store.
Six spoons of snow peas, five
thick slabs of blue cheese,
and maybe a snack for
her brother Bob.
We also need a small plastic --
>> So you can listen to all that.
I'm sure you were able to
follow along with the phonetics
that we wrote there for you.
The phonetic inventories that
are included in the archive,
for each of the languages,
at least 210 of them,
are given in some form like this.
They're all uniform and you can
compare Vietnamese to English
and find out why a Vietnamese
speaker is doing what she is doing
when she speaks English or why a
German speaker does what she does
when she speaks English.
And the search facility
looks something like this.
You can point it to searches on
all the data on the archives.
So for research, the data is
freely available, has a uniform --
it's uniform so that you can use it
to compare one accent to another,
because everyone's
reading the same thing.
It's turning into a
massive database,
so a lot of speech engineers
are asking for it to use
to train their machines
to understand speech.
And we are now understanding
with the archive a little better
of what it means to have an accent,
what it means to scientifically
study an accent,
and what affects an accent.
Some of the most crucial
factors involved
in accent are listed right there.
What your native language is,
when you began to learn English
or study English, your
length of residence
and where, and your learning style.
And it's quite useful.
Thank you.
I think I made it within
five minutes.
>> My name is Chelsea Stieber, and
I'm going to be talking to you today
about Caribbean periodicals.
Just to introduce myself,
I am a Kluge fellow
at the Kluge Center here
at the Library of Congress,
and in my other life, I am a
professor at the Catholic University
of America, Assistant Professor
in French and Francophone Studies.
So yes, I'm going to be
talking to you about periodicals
and the catalog, more specifically
about a project I'm developing here
with a group of scholars on a
specific Haitian periodical,
The Journal of the Haitian Society
of History, Geography, and Geology.
So every good digital
humanities project has a problem
and a solution, so I'll present
those here in the short time I have.
So this journal is Haiti's most
significant social science journal
of the 20th century.
It's actually still around.
It was founded in 1923.
It's almost 100 years of
scholarship, over 250 issues.
It's the most important repository
of locally produced knowledge
and of academic and social science
research coming out of Haiti.
And yet, and here's the problem,
US and really North American
and North Atlantic
academics don't cite it.
They don't use it.
It's really rarely used and
read and it's not part of sort
of our academic discourse.
And so the question is why?
And there are a lot of reasons why.
I certainly don't have
the time to get into here,
and it would take us hours
and hours to discuss,
but there is one really
interesting reason why,
and it's something I discovered
while doing my research here
at the Library, and that is
specifically how periodicals exist
in the Library space and
in the Library catalog.
Periodicals, when they come into
the Library, they are cataloged,
but they are not indexed.
So here I have a reproduction
of the catalog entry
for this Social Science Journal,
and here we have a representation
of 100 years of scholarship, local
Caribbean knowledge production,
that is effectively
illegible in the catalog.
That is, we have our subject
heading, Haiti Periodicals,
and actually the title
itself is quite explanatory,
but beyond that we don't
know what's inside.
And this isn't an indictment
of the Library catalog,
this is precisely how the catalog is
supposed to work, but the problem is
that we don't get to know what's
inside, because it's not indexed.
And I think this is specifically
important for the Caribbean,
and the global South more broadly,
because periodicals like this,
this journal, this is
where knowledge production is
happening in the 20th century.
It's the privileged medium for
Caribbean academic research,
for local knowledge
production, and for scholarship.
And with this content
being virtually illegible
to our searching, it's no wonder
that people aren't
using it or citing it.
So with that in mind, we
decided to try and come
up with a project to solve that.
So what we're trying to do is
expand access to this journal
and the impact of this
scholarship, this 100 years
of scholarship that
the Library holds.
And, in fact, the Library is one of
the few that has a nearly full run
of this journal, and so we
really wanted to highlight it
and get people citing it, get people
using it in academic research.
So we finished Phase
One of our project,
which is to create a database.
So we, this team, we've basically
indexed every issue of the Journal,
subject, headings, and
so on and so forth,
and so now we have our database.
And the next step of the
project is to develop a scholarly
and collaborative space for
people to access the content
in searchable form and
engage with the scholarship.
And here I just wanted to sort
of shout out and cite some people
who are doing really best practices
in Caribbean digital scholarship,
and that is the folks at Small
Axe Archipelagos, and I just want
to read from their website.
And if you haven't heard
of them, check them out.
They are great.
"How might we encourage
collaboration with,
increase accessibility for, and
otherwise work to narrow the gap
between Caribbeanist
researchers, especially those
in the North Atlantic Academy,
and the communities we
are committed to serving."
And so as we move forward
into Phase Two,
building this collaborative
space, which will be a site
with labs.loc.gov, we wanted
to take this idea as sort
of our driving focus or inspiration,
which is going to take sort
of the desire to reactivate this
library holding, this rich holding
in the library collection, and
make it available to researchers,
not just in this North
Atlantic space,
but also in the Caribbean as well.
So we're envisioning annotations,
translations, thematic groupings
of content, creating a dynamic,
vibrant space that will
improve access and impact
to this Caribbean periodical.
Again, this is in the works,
it's still in development now,
and so I would love to hear from you
if you have questions,
ideas, advice, thoughts.
This, already, conference
today has been
so illuminating for
that reason for me.
So please, I'll be here after the
conference, but also for those
of you virtually who are
tuning into the live stream,
please tweet at me and be in touch.
Thank you very much.
>> Good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Kevin Schlottmann.
I am the Digital Archives Manager
at the New York Philharmonic,
and today I'm going to talk
about, in my five minutes here,
the New York Philharmonic
subscriber's project.
It's a project that we did
in conjunction with a group
of sociologists whose names and
affiliations you see up here
with support from the
Mellon Foundation.
You can tweet us @nyphilarchive
and today's hashtag is #asdata.
Before I go into the project, I
just very briefly want to talk
about the mass digitization
that we are doing.
Since 2008, we have been supported
by the Leon Levy Foundation
to the tune of $5 million
to digitize every last scrap
of paper in our archives.
Our archives go back to 1842 and
document the oldest orchestra
in North America and one of
the three oldest in the world.
We have extremely rich and
deep archives in a variety
of formats including music, we
not only have scores and parts
that are interesting in their
own right, but they are marked
by the conductors who have
led the New York Philharmonic
and the musicians who have played
in the New York Philharmonic
for the last 175 years.
So these provide a tremendous
insight into the development
of orchestral performance practice.
We have a complete set of
programs going back to 1842,
from which we have
also extracted data,
which I'll talk about
more in a moment.
Photos, of course, 10,000 folders
of business records are archived,
ranging from minutes, posters,
correspondence, down to [inaudible],
things like receipts
and that sort of thing.
As well as 70,000 pages of
press clippings dating back
to the very early 20th century,
essentially every mention
of the New York Philharmonic in
the American press, both national
and local, as well as a lot of
international press as well.
So the subscribers project,
we have information relating
to our subscribers, so people
who bought more than one ticket
or people who bought
tickets to a series,
dating all the way back to 1842.
And we have -- we know their
names, we know their addresses,
we know what seats they bought,
we know for how long they were
engaged with the orchestra.
A couple of years after we
launched the digital archives,
a group of sociologists approached
us and asked, can we do something
with this subscriber data?
We have some thoughts.
And since it had been
digitized, it was relatively easy,
and I say relatively
because underscoring a point
that many people have made today,
there's a lot of human labor
that goes into extracting
data from these things.
But it was relatively easy to take
the digitized 19th century books
that you see here on
the right and turn it
into a nice adjacent data set.
They originally were
going to look at trying
to correlate social status
using addresses of proxy
with where people were
actually sitting in the hall.
They ended up going a
slightly different direction,
but that was their initial impetus.
And then when they were done,
they gave the data to us
and we have this nice
little web widget
where people can search a
select portion of the data
and also the entire
subscriber data set is available
as a CSV download from our website.
It's an anonymized post-1951 to
protect the more recent folks,
but all the data's there for
anybody who wants to use it.
So what did the sociologists
actually find?
Well, when they got into
the data, they dug in
and they gave us a more nuanced
understanding of the nature
of 19th century social status.
I think this is really interesting
to me because they use the data
to -- we know the kind
of the big picture
of gilded era social consolidation,
but they used the data
to find something that they
called segregated inclusion,
which I'm going to read it.
I apologize.
"It's a form of inclusion
that preserved the purity
and distinctiveness
of the social elite
by allowing the non-elite cultural
experts access to the concert hall,
but in a limited way that
reified the high-class status
of the orchestra and
its subscribers."
So that's a really nice, nuanced
twist on our understanding
of how 19th century social
conglomeration worked in New York.
It's a wonderful paper.
It's coming out next year in
a leading sociology journal.
And not only did they use
our subscriber database,
they also used our
performance database.
So we have data for every
performance going back to 1842,
where it happened, when it
happened, what the repertoire was,
who the conductor was,
who the soloists were,
whether it was an encore, and all
of that data is available both
on our website at the
performance history,
as well as downloadable data
on XML and JSON on GitHub
that I update on a monthly basis.
So you can look up our entire
performance repertoire,
pretty much up to date
whenever you want.
All of our archives are available
for free at archives.nyphil.org.
Go check it out, and
in my last 30 seconds,
I'd just like to say I thank
you to the sociologists
for approaching us
in doing this work.
Thanks to LC for hosting
us all here today.
Thanks to my colleagues in the
archives, especially Barbara Haws,
who has been the archivist and
historian at the Philharmonic
for many years and is really
the driver behind this
digitization project.
And to the Leon Levy Foundation,
who have been kind enough to fund us
for all of this digitization.
Thank you.
>> Ascension Mazuela.
I am glad to be here.
Alan Lomax recorded
hundreds of songs in Spain
between June 1952 and
[inaudible] 1953.
[inaudible] of this journey
include music on magnetic tape,
but also photographs,
notebooks, voices, letters,
and diaries preserved at
the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
[inaudible] my research is to
analyze the documents in order
to establish connections between
the songs recorded by Lomax in Spain
and other collections of the
Spanish traditional music such as
that preserved at the Spanish
National Research Council
in Barcelona.
Although it includes
some music recordings,
the Barcelona collection is
primarily made up of more
than 20,000 folk songs
copied on paper
and collected throughout
Spain between 1944 and 1960.
Most of them, through the
[inaudible] commissioned
by the former Spanish
Institute of Musicology.
Since the materials at
Library of Congress and those
in Barcelona were collected
around the same time,
often in the same villages, and
even using the same performers,
it is clear that the collections
complement one another,
but to what extent is still unknown.
The Barcelona collection is
being digitized and cataloged
in an open-access database
into which they have
incorporated the details provided
by the Lomax collection.
Cataloging information on all the
songs [inaudible] recorded by Lomax
in Spain including his photographs
and links to all the files.
I have also cataloged
and transcribed documents
such as notebooks, letters
and diaries, connected them
to the music, people, and
locations to which they refer,
and including links to the
corresponding digitization
on the Library of Congress website.
The [inaudible] have
prepared a collection
for [inaudible] comparison and it
is possible to identify concordances
between this collection at
the Library of Congress,
and that in Barcelona,
[inaudible] locations,
[inaudible] musical
genres and songs.
The Barcelona collection
includes, for instance,
several songs performed
by this woman
from a small [inaudible] village
in the form of transcriptions made
by the Spanish [inaudible] in 1951.
[inaudible] later, Lomax recorded
20 songs performed by the same woman
in the same place, and some of them
coincide with those transcribed
by [inaudible], as in this example.
[ Foreign language ]
>> [inaudible], I am using the
database as a research tool
for interpreting data on
[inaudible] on the meaning
of these concordances
[inaudible] Spain,
in order to assess how this
[inaudible] would determine his
[inaudible] and the music and
people he chose to record.
This digital tool also makes data
accessible to other researchers.
At the same time, through the
database and the social networks
to which it is connected,
Lomax's contribution
to Spanish traditional
music can be better known
and appreciated by
a general audience.
In order to provide a different
approach both to the database
and to the Lomax Spanish collection,
I am creating a story map
which presents Lomax's
itinerary [inaudible] Spain,
connecting each town to an example
of the music recorded there,
to a related [inaudible]
belonging to the Lomax collection
and to a link to the complete
information concerning
that location on the database.
The main purpose of this application
is to make data more visible,
not only to researchers, but also
to our [inaudible] audience
outside the [inaudible] context.
Thus, as a researcher,
I have benefitted
from making this collection
available as data.
[inaudible] able to analyze,
compare and interpret information
in order to produce [inaudible].
At the same time, the accessibility
of the collection [inaudible] easily
searchable in an interactive way
through the database and the map
application allows descendents
of the performers and school
teachers, and the community
in general to use and enjoy
this magnificent collection,
increasing the sociological impact.
Thank you.
>> This is a picture
of a bunch of numbers.
I guess that's a joke.
But imagine this is a file, right?
And what I'm hoping to do in the
next five minutes is convince you
that this is a collection
of data, and not only that,
but that it's a useful
collection of data.
So I work on a project
called Documenting the Now,
which is a Mellon funded project
to help build social media
archiving tools and practices,
with a particular focus on Twitter,
which is kind of a third-rail
type of topic here, but --
And so I thought I would --
and actually my collaborator that I
work with, Burgess [inaudible] spoke
at this event last year, and maybe
some of you remember his talk.
He -- this is one slide that he
had that he showed and Burgess,
when he was here, was
really trying to impress
on everyone the importance of
doing social media archiving
in the context of large
state and corporate actors
that are also doing social
media archiving for the purposes
of surveillance and control, right?
And so our project is
interested in memory, right?
So we're remembering social media
for the purposes of cultural memory,
but at the same time, we
have actors like Geofeedia,
who are sort of building
social media collections
that they are then advertising to
a police department in California
that they can help the
police department sort
of manage the Ferguson
situation, right?
And so the challenge that
we've been working on is well,
how do we do social media
archiving while this is going on?
How do we do it in an ethical
way that respects the voices
and the content of the people that
are creating the content, right?
That's kind of the
challenge that we've had.
And so there's no silver
bullet here.
There's no technical solution that's
really going to do this for us,
but we found -- the one
little silver lining
that we found is actually in
Twitter's terms of service itself.
They actually don't allow people --
so you have to agree to the terms
of service to get data from
Twitter, and one of the rules
that they have is that you can't
download data and then just sort
of put it on the web, right?
You can't download millions
of tweets and then sort
of put them in an archive.
Because for them, it's sort
of a business decision, right?
They have reasons why they
don't want that to happen.
But one of the interesting
things that they do let you do is
to take a file of tweet IDs, so
each tweet has a numeric identifier
that identifies it, and they do
allow you to distribute those.
And what you can do with a tweet
identifier, then, is then go back
to Twitter's API and get
the data for that tweet.
An interesting thing
that happens there is
that if the tweet has been
deleted or if the user has decided
to protect their account
or delete their account,
you can no longer get that tweet.
So it kind of empowers the user,
it gives them some level of control
over how their content is
used elsewhere on the web.
Which leads me to one -- I
should've said at the beginning--
talk about two applications.
If I don't run out of time.
But this is the first application
that I was going to mention.
It's called the catalog.
And really all the catalog is, is --
I mean really, it's just a web page
that lists data sets of tweet IDs
that different researchers have
created for different purposes,
and sort of put them in one place
so that other researchers
can find them.
And so they have a description
of the data set, who created it,
how many tweets are in it, what
date range, that kind of stuff,
why they created it,
and then a link to go
to a repository that's
somewhere else on the web, right,
so this is just a clearinghouse for
the data sets that live elsewhere,
and they can download it.
And so once you download it, you end
up with something like this, right,
a file with a bunch
of numbers in it.
And so the other application I
thought I'd mention really quick,
is the hydrator application,
which basically,
it's a desktop application
you download
and run on your own workstation.
It will read a data set of tweet IDs
and do what they call hydrate them,
so turn them back into the data
that is useful for research.
And one of the other things it does
is it will convert the Twitter JSON
data to CSV that once
it's finished downloading.
We heard a little bit about
CSV earlier from [inaudible].
It's like a format that's used
a lot in all kinds of analysis.
So actually that's
really the majority
of what I wanted to talk about.
So I see that my time is up.
So these are a few
URLs if you're curious.
The top one has links
to everything else,
the two applications I talked about.
So thanks for your time.
>> Good afternoon.
I'm Paul Farber.
I'm the Artistic Director of
Monument Lab, a public art
and history project
based in Philadelphia.
Thank you to the Library of
Congress for hosting us all today.
In my day job, I'm a historian
and curator, and I represent
and lead a collective of scholars,
curators, artists and students
around this project since 2014.
And we're interested in
building temporary monuments
in public spaces, and
data sets that endure
in libraries and online
as open data.
We're gearing up for a big fall 2017
citywide exhibition in Philadelphia
with the Mural Arts Program.
Our project centers
around a question.
What is an appropriate monument for
the current city of Philadelphia?
We have a city full of public
art and statues, murals,
but sometimes we need assistance
to fill in what is there.
So this project is one where we use
this question to invite people in.
We ask artists to build temporary
monuments and we ask this
to the public as a way to measure
both the expected, or the municipal,
and also understand the possible,
the dreamed, the speculative,
the haunts of the city to
have a more complete vision
of our historical landscape.
We're working with 20
artists from around the world
and around Philadelphia
who are going
to be building these
monuments in public spaces.
Some will use the kind of
traditional formats, bronze,
granite, but others are going to
build their monuments with sound,
light, performance, interactivity.
Many of these artists take
on issues of social justice,
especially around race,
gender, sexuality, class,
national belonging, to make sure
that our monumental landscape
represents a city founded
on freedom, justice, and toleration.
Their works will be sited
around the city of Philadelphia
in our five central squares
that go back to the 1680s,
and five neighborhood parks.
At each of these sites, there's
at least one temporary monument
and a learning lab, where
we use this research form.
On this form, we ask the
public to name their monuments,
place it somewhere in the city,
an address, an intersection,
a neighborhood, though
that often is broken.
You'll see in a moment.
We also ask them in a big open
space to describe or sketch.
In addition, if people want to leave
their home zip code, their age,
their social media handle,
they can add that on as well.
This is not the first
time that we've done this.
Back in 2015 in the
courtyard of City Hall,
we had our Discovery Phase,
thanks to the Pew Center
for Arts and Heritage.
Here, our temporary monument
by the late Terry Adkins,
was an empty classroom to comment
on educational pride that we have
in the city, and also the fact of
budget cuts and school closures
that marked our current
civic landscape.
In addition to this classroom, we
had the different kind of classroom,
the learning lab, where teams mostly
of youth researchers from college
and high school would
gather public proposals.
In the three and a half weeks that
we were in the City Hall courtyard,
we had 455 people leave monument
proposals, we had 4000 people come
to free programs every day, and over
30,000 people visit the monument.
When you see these pieces here,
this comprises an imagination
of the city, and on one hand each
piece matters and the data set
as a whole both stand out.
For each piece, it can be seen
in the lab itself at a museum
or gallery and is deposited
in a local library.
Some snapshots here.
Dancing with love in your step,
right in the heart of the city.
Door to door, an imaginative
portal between neighborhoods.
In the City of Brotherly Love,
I don't love you, but I -- .
Of course there's poignant and
important forms of truth-telling.
Someone who's wary of the murder
crisis in our city called attention
to the shrines around the
city at sites of violence.
Others were more poetic, blurring
the boundary between the vision
of a statue or just an
exchange between Philadelphians.
And then, of course, the complex.
Like Claes Oldenburg said,
"Proposing monuments is
like composing with the city."
In addition to the individuals,
you can see the data set.
You can see it on a
map, across the city.
We've also transcribed and
analyzed and done initial level
of classification that
is on Open Data Philly,
the portal for civic data in the
city, so alongside crime statistics
and traffic incidents, this data
set that is powered by speculation,
by cultural memory, is available.
Ultimately our goal is to change
the way that we write the history
of our city together,
and we take up the call
for cultural heritage organizations
to find new ways to bring in voices,
people, and data, not just
to be powered by imagination,
but also to co-author the next
chapters of our city's history.
Thank you.
>> Hi. My name is Jared Nielsen.
I'm an artist and instructor at
George Washington University,
where I teach full
stack web development.
I recently discovered the
digital collections available
to the public on LC's website.
If you haven't discovered
it yourself,
I highly recommend browsing this.
You'll lose hours of your day.
It's a fantastic collection.
There's on collection in
particular that caught my eye.
There's this pictorial of St. Louis.
It's a series of plates that were
published as an atlas in 1875
by the artist Camille Dry.
This was created at this time as
an act of boosterism by the city
when they were making a bid to
become the nation's capital,
but they thought their
position on the Mississippi,
being a massive trade economic
route was more suitable
for our nation's future
than this current swamp.
These plates are incredibly
detailed and beautiful,
and one other thing I
thought was really interesting
when I found these is that
there was no technology used
in their creation.
There's no airplane,
there's no hot air balloon.
This was all Camille Dry and
his team beating the pavement,
making these records, and
then transposing their 2D data
into a 3D aerial perspective
representation.
So here's a little more
of the detail here.
So the atlas was published with
a key that shows you where,
which plates where they lined up
with their geographic position
in relation to St. Louis.
Because these were all hand-drawn,
some of the plates have
these interesting features
where a landmark is breaking the
frame and I wanted to keep this
when I -- well, first, let me
just say when I discovered this,
I wanted to do something with this.
If we step back to the key, I wanted
to see all the plates stitched
together as one large map.
And this is one of the
issues I encountered, though,
is when stitching these
together, there are a lot
of these breaks with the frame.
So I cleaned up all of these,
but I left these landmark details
and inserted some space
into the map.
And I had to convert it to
grayscale because this became
such a massive image file that the
only way for me to pull this off was
to strip out all the colored
data and go grayscale.
So this is a small
version of the final image,
which if anyone here
works with digital images,
you know that an image that's 64,000
by 20,000 pixels is a monster.
So this was -- the size is roughly
like 900 megabytes, so that's huge.
It was kind of crippling
my workstation.
Like my GPU was really
struggling to keep up with this.
So I have a background in
exhibit design in museums also,
and in a couple exhibits I worked
on, we used open frameworks
and processing to handle interactive
images, and I tried running this
through those programs and
it was just killing them.
And I wasn't sure what to
do, so I asked myself --
my goal is to keep this
interactive in a way
where the detail wouldn't be lost,
but we could also still have this
like pulled-out global scope.
So I thought, well how
does Google Maps work?
So I googled it, "how
does Google Maps work?"
And I found this great
framework Leaflet.
It's an open search
JavaScript library
that has really great robust
tutorials and it's very,
very easy and simple to implement.
And through a little more Google-fu,
I found these fantastic [inaudible]
on GitHub that helped me piece
together this non-geographic
story map.
So Leaflet is intended
specifically for geographic maps,
for geospatial data abstraction
layers, and I was kind
of perverting it by using
these non-geographical,
these raster images.
So I found this one here,
Raster [inaudible] that was key
in being able to pull this off.
This is maybe the least
dynamic slide that I have,
but maybe the most important.
This is a directory structure.
This is my file tree.
When I -- through Leaflet,
I needed to splice
that big image up into
smaller tiles.
So here you can see how
the tiles are nested.
This is like the levels and
these are all the thumbnails.
And each of these is 256 pixels.
So we've all had this experience
when we're on a slow data connection
and we're using Google Maps and
we see the little squares pop up
and then they slowly
come into focus.
That map tiling in action.
You're seeing map tiling happening.
This is what map tiling
looks like on a server.
So I'm going to step through
these zoom slides and I want you
to pay attention to this
upper left hand corner,
because this is zero,
zero in our coordinates.
We're going to zoom
in on zero, zero.
So my map had eight layers and we
just zoomed through eight layers.
And my time is up, so I
have to move really quickly.
JavaScript is awesome.
This is one of the reasons why.
You can really simply
implement this map yourself.
That's all it takes.
I needed help so I asked
the librarian at the LC
for some background information
on Camille Dry and this map.
If you haven't used Ask A Librarian
service, I highly recommend it.
Within a week I received several
scanned PDFs that were highlighted,
no less, of the pertinent
information that I needed.
I plugged it into a
JSON file like this,
and this is the final end result.
If you want to see it in action,
you can do so at this URL.
If you want the [inaudible], build
this yourself locally, go here,
and I wrote a tutorial on
medium that you can find here.
Thank you.
>> My name is Bill Ferster.
I'm with the University of Virginia
at the -- actually it's hard to say.
It's the Science, Humanities, Arts,
and Humanities Technology
Initiative.
It's kind of a little
thing, but -- .
So anyway, what I've come here today
to show you is a tool
called Visualize.
And Visualize is a tool
that was designed by us
for use in two different areas.
One is for teaching classes,
interactively in a
project-based setting,
pretty much like what
you saw the people doing,
the students earlier in.
And also we use it for making
scholarly arguments using historical
data, using primary
sources, historical data.
So basically what it is, is we've
connected a timeline, a story panel,
and a slippy map all
together and put it in so
that you can actually
make things with it.
And on top of that map, you can
overlay things on top of it,
and there are geo reference,
and things like that.
So you can have dots
or things on top of it.
You can have interactive graphics.
You can have KML files, which are
basically vector overlays on top
of it, or historic maps, and
that becomes quite useful.
So also we've got a variety of other
kinds of tools that you can use
to make your presentation.
So you can -- this is a drawing tool
built in, so you can draw things
on it, and then you can do, kind of
pan and zoom maps, and Choropleths,
which are a way of showing data
relationships on top of maps.
This tool basically
is all web-based,
and it's very easy to use.
And the idea is instead of
things like [inaudible],
which are very robust tools
for doing geographic
information system type work,
these are easily used by
humanity scholars or by students.
And the key to our -- the way that
we've set it up is we've tried
to use a very distributed process.
So I came from UVA.
We had a place called the
Virginia Center for Digital History
that Ed Ayers had started, and we
used to use all databases back then,
and these very complex [inaudible]
databases, and what really came
down is humanities scholars
typically have a big table,
for the most part, and it's X
number of fields about the thing
and then a whole bunch of events.
And so what we did is said,
well, we don't need all
that complicated database.
Let's try and use a spreadsheet.
And the advantage of using a
spreadsheet is that Google has built
in all this incredible sharing
techniques within the spreadsheet.
And so -- and the spreadsheet is
connected live to the visualization.
They told me actually I
couldn't use the internet,
so I would've actually shown
it live here, but the idea is
that you change one thing on
the spreadsheet and it changes
on the visualization, and
it's also stored there
so people have more
autonomy with their data.
And for classroom use,
it works out quite well.
Anyway, so it was funded by the
NEH, which funded us in a variety
of different projects for the
Digital Humanities Project.
It's free to use and
HTML-based and open source.
And anybody can just look on it.
It's www.viseyes.org, and that
brings up a page which has a variety
of different tools
that we make at Shanti.
And if you need to get
a hold of me I'm there.
So thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.